Here's a question for you.
Remember when the future seemed to be a place with
flying cars and robots and
people traveling through space?
Back then, technology meant promise and potential.
Americans were much more optimistic about
the role it would play in their daily lives.
Fast forward to today and
that optimism seems to be vanishing.
Reports of automation, artificial intelligence,
and self-driving vehicles
replacing human workers are everywhere.
Even with near record low unemployment,
Americans are more and more concerned
about losing their jobs
because of new technologies.
Jobs in manufacturing, in the service sector,
and in retail are especially vulnerable.
Here's one example straight from the headlines.
Nearly three million Americans drive trucks for a living.
If self-driving technology develops at its current pace,
these jobs could vanish
in the next ten to fifteen years.
In addition, accountants, doctors and lawyers
were once thought to be impervious to disruption.
But even these better-paying professions
could be redefined with massive
shifts in how work is done.
Technological disruption has come as
wages have stagnated for decades,
income inequality has increased,
and the middle class has shrunk.
So how can the United States prepare for this disruption
and build new opportunities for its workers?
The past might offers some answers.
More than a hundred years ago,
during the height of the Industrial Revolution,
new technologies gave rise to new ways of working.
Technologies like electricity, the steam engine,
the telephone, and the automobile
all required different skills from American workers.
The United States responded by expanding free
public education and training opportunities,
far outpacing any other country.
In just thirty years, the number of
school-age children attending high school
skyrocketed from 18 to 73 percent.
And those completing their schooling
went from 9 to 51 percent.
The link between education and
good jobs is even clearer today.
Most jobs created by retiring baby boomers
require advanced degrees or specialized training.
Yet, more than half of all Americans have
only a high school education or less.
That means even more good jobs
are at risk of going unfilled.
So what can be done?
The first step is to see education
and work as closely linked.
Almost half of U.S. companies complain that
too few graduates leave school with
the skills they need to enter the workforce.
For younger students, this means
a greater focus on work-study programs,
early job-oriented counseling, internships, apprenticeships and career-related coursework.
Companies, educational institutions and
government should help support programs
that allow workers to learn new skills
at every stage of their careers.
So that's how workers get trained for the future,
but how do we ensure that those
who have acquired skills get jobs?
Unfortunately, the United States
has a big matching problem.
Sometimes, this means there aren't enough
workers where jobs are being created.
For example, the rust belt might lose manufacturing
jobs while Silicon Valley is booming.
Here too we can look to the past.
In the 1950s and 60s, Americans were
the most mobile people in the world.
When jobs were scarce in one part of the country,
they would move to where jobs were more plentiful.
That doesn't happen as much today.
One culprit is that booming urban areas lack
affordable housing and public transportation
to get people to where the jobs are located.
Another major obstacle is excessive state
and local credentialing and licensing requirements.
For example, the country's three million teachers
must have state-issued licenses
in order to work in school systems.
Yet, most states don't recognize
licenses issued by other states.
It's not just teachers.
Bartenders, interior decorators,
cosmetologists, manicurists, and even florists
typically require some sort of state license
that's not recognized across state lines.
Sometimes the matching problem means
employers demand college degrees
for jobs that don't require them, or overlook good applicants who lack work experience.
Here we can look to the future.
Big data will empower employers to use more
precise job matching behind the scenes
and to share credential requirements.
It can also help applicants showcase their
abilities to the largest number of companies.
This all sounds pretty good,
but what else is needed to create more
opportunities for the American workforce?
Federal, state, and local governments should
provide better services for workers
transitioning from one job to another.
Things like skills retraining and
job counseling are crucial
and will be even more essential for those working
in ways unimaginable to previous generations.
The United States currently provides just a small
fraction of what most European countries do
to help workers who lose their jobs
retrain for new careers.
In addition, support systems such as health care,
sick leave, family leave, and retirement benefits,
are generally only available to full-time workers.
Low-wage, part-time, and independent contractors,
are making up a larger and larger
share of the U.S. workforce.
These employment benefits could be tied to the worker
rather than to the job throughout their careers.
Education, retraining, mobility, and support systems
might sound like tall orders for the country.
But remember, the United States has
overcome large challenges in the past.
We need to do it again.
Nothing less than the future of
the U.S. workforce depends on it.